X
NEWS.
JOINING ME HERE TONIGHT OUR
G.O.P. CONGRESSMAN AND
AFGHANISTAN WAR VETERAN BRIAN
MAST AND JIM BANKS.
I WAS LISTENING TO THAT,
GENTLEMEN.
AND WAS SHOCKED IT WAS LIKE I
WAS SITTING IN A BORING SEMINAR
AT STANFORD WITH SOMEONE
SPOUTING THINGS THAT WERE RATHER
BIZARRE.
ONE OF MY -- ONE OF THE
REMARKABLE THINGS I MADE A NOTE
OF WAS HIS COMMENT THAT WE WERE
GOING TO CONTINUE WITH DIPLOMACY
NOW THAT'S THE SHIFT BUT WE ALL
ALL RUN OVER FROM QATAR IT'S
GOING TO BE FROM DOHA.
CONGRESSMAN MAST YOUR THOUGHTS.
NUMBER ONE WHAT YOU SAID THEY
ARE GOING TO CONTINUE DIPLOMACY
WHEN THEY COULDN'T EVEN CONDUCT
DIPLOMACY WHEN THEY HAD MILITARY
ON THE GROUND.
THAT'S NUMBER ONE.
NUMBER TWO, PROBABLY THE MOST
DIRE THING THAT I HEARD HIM SAY
WAS THIS THAT THE TALIBAN MADE A
COMMITMENT TO NOT ALLOW
AFGHANISTAN TO BECOME A
TERRORIST SAFE HAVEN.
LET'S BREAK THAT DOWN.
THE TERRORISTS SAID THEY WON'T
ALLOW THAT COUNTRY TO BECOME A
TERRORIST SAFE HAVEN.
THAT MAKES YOU WONDER ABOUT
BLINKEN STATE DEPARTMENT BIND AT
EVERY POSSIBLE LEVEL.
>> Tammy: STUNNING.
I MADE SO MANY NOTES OF WHAT WE
ARE DEALING WITH HERE BECAUSE WE
HAVE GOT SUCH A SHOCKING
DEVELOPMENT IN GENERAL THAT THIS
IS SEEMINGLY OVER AND, YET,
THERE ARE, I THINK, UNTOLD
NUMBERS CONGRESSMAN BANKS ABOUT
HOW MANY AMERICANS ARE STILL
LEFT.
IT SEEMS TO BE INCREDIBLY
SHRINKING NUMBER AND NOW IT'S AT
100.
THEY HAD TROUBLE GIVING US A
NUMBER EARLY ON AND NOW IT'S
THIS MAGICAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WHO JUST SOMEHOW WANT TO STAY.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ABOUT
WHAT YOU JUST HEARD?
>> WELL, YOU HEARD HIM SAY IT'S
AROUND HUNDRED BUT CLOSER TO
100.
AN HOUR OR SO AGO THE STATE
DEPARTMENT SAID 250.
THEN YOU HAVE GENERAL McKENZIE
JUST SAID MOMENTS AGO IT'S IN
THE FEW HUNDREDS OF AMERICANS
WHO ARE STILL LEFT BEHIND ENEMY
LINES.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS THEY
DON'T KNOW.
THEY DON'T KNOW HOW MANY
AMERICANS THAT THEY HAVE LEFT
BEHIND.
AND THE FURTHERMORE, IT'S
UNFATHOMABLE TO ME THAT WE WOULD
LEAVE ANY AMERICAN BEHIND.
THESE GUYS DECIDED THAT THEY
WOULD BOW DOWN TO THE TALIBAN
AND ABIDE BY THE TALIBAN'S
DEADLINE AND THEIR RED LINES.
I NEVER IN MY LIFE THOUGHT I
WOULD SEE AN AMERICAN PRESIDENT
KOWTOW TO A TERRORIST GROUP LIKE
THE TALIBAN BUT THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT JOE BIDEN AND HIS TEAM HAVE
DONE AND AT THIS POINT SINCE THE
LAST EVACUATION THE LAST PLANE
HAS LEFT, YOU NOW KNOW THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE NOW KNOW THAT
THIS PRESIDENT HAS DONE
SOMETHING NO PRESIDENT IN
AMERICAN HISTORY HAS DONE
BEFORE.
HE LEFT AMERICANS BEHIND.
IT'S DISGRACEFUL AND HE SHOULD
BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR IT.
>> Tammy: REPRESENTATIVE MAST WE
HEARD JACQUI HEINRICH EARLIER
THAT THE LAST FIVE TRANSPORTS
THAT DID NOT INCLUDE ANY
AMERICANS.
WE KNOW FROM RESCUERS WE HAVE
INCREDIBLE GROUPS OF AMERICANS
RESCUING ON THESE KIND OF RAND
DOM KIND OF FLIGHTS OF THINGS
THAT THEY HAVE ARRANGED
PRIVATELY TO RESCUE PEOPLE.
IS THIS A DYNAMIC THAT WE CAN
EVEN COMPREHEND HERE THAT
PRIVATE AMERICANS, INCLUDING
THIS NETWORK RESCUING OVER TWO
DOZEN PEOPLE WHO HAD WORKED WITH
US AND THEIR FAMILIES OUT OF
AFGHANISTAN, HOW DOES OUR
GOVERNMENT DO THAT?
HOW DO THEY NOT EVEN PRY TO MAKE
THIS WORK WHERE HAVE YOU PRIVATE
CITIZENS MAKING WORK IN THE
MEANTIME?
>> I THINK YOU ACTUALLY TOUCHED
ON THE ONE SILVER LINING, THE
ONE BRIGHT SPOT IN THE MIDST OF
ALL OF THIS HORROR THERE IS
STILL A FEW AMERICANS OVER THERE
THAT ARE SHOWING THE WORLD WHO
AMERICA IS.
JUST LIKE THOSE MARINES THAT
GAVE THEIR LIVES.
AMERICANS THAT ARE STEPPING UP,
IN AND OUT OF UNIFORM TO SAY YOU
KNOW WHAT?
THERE IS A LINE THAT WE ARE NOT
GOING TO LET YOU PASS.
THERE IS A POINT THAT YOU WILL
NOT GO BEYOND.
THAT'S WHAT THOSE AMERICANS ARE
GOING OUT THERE SAYING.
THEY ARE SHOWING THE WORLD THESE
ARE THE LIONS THAT AMERICANS
REALLY ARE DON'T LOOK AT THIS
LAMB THAT'S STANDING IN FRONT OF
US, PRESIDENT BIDEN.
THIS IS THE REAL AMERICA.
NOT THE LAND THAT'S HOLDING UP
THE RIGHT FLAG OF SURRENDER TO
MOVE OUT OF BAGRAM.
TO SAY MOVE OUT OF THE EMBASSY.
TO MOVE OUT OF THE COUNTRY ON
THE TIMELINE OF THE TERRORIST.
THAT'S THE ONLY BRIGHT SPOT THAT
I CAN POINT TO IN THE MIDST.
>> Tammy: IT'S A REMINDER OF WHO
WE ARE WHAT WE STAND FOR AND
WHAT WE ARE WILLING TO
ACCOMPLISH RAPING FROM INSTAGRAM
CELEBRITY TO TELEVISION NETWORK
TO OTHER RETIRED MILITARY.
EVERYONE WORKING TO TRY TO MAKE
THIS RIGHT.
GENTLEMEN, YOU BOTH MADE A